so I did that video that 140 on
gamergate last week and I was on the
David Pakman show talking about
gamergate so I've been doing a little
research on this whole gamergate thing
and as I'm doing it as I talked about
last week it's it's just a giant freakin
mess I don't know exactly what's going
on i'm not sure if i'm gonna do any more
videos on it cuz i don't know that i can
add anything substantive to it i think i
may just help make more of a mess and
there's plenty of people out there doing
that so i may skip and i'm not sure
we'll see we'll see um but as i've been
doing all this gamergate research i've
been jumping on youtube in a bunch of
other sites and sort of getting back
into the video game thing I used to be a
huge gamer mostly when I was in high
school college little after college for
me it started with the original 8-bit
Nintendo this is a long time ago we had
to actually blow in the cartridges to
get them to work if you get that
reference I like what you're doing yet
we literally because there would be
Dustin we have to blow in the cartridge
to get it going we agree codes like up
up down down left right left right ba
select start that's contra right there I
think was a few other Konami games as
well um and it was making me think like
so that I was looking around I'm seeing
all these the new games right the new
games and everyone's on these games all
day long and they talk about games
addiction and people are playing these
games online they can't get off and
people are sometimes playing more than
12 hours a day and if you're pretty much
playing more than 12 hours day that
means most of your life is on there and
then you get into some kind of matrix
stuff which is the real reality that
you're living in are you just battery
for the game that's a whole other
deepest optical at you uh it was made me
think are these games cuz I played some
of them I played on you know an xbox and
everything in PlayStation 7 or whatever
they got as I don't know these games
anymore fun are they actually more fun
they look a lot fancier and there's a
lot more blood and you can play Grand
Theft Auto you can punch a hooker and
you can you know go to that halo there
you can kill a lot of people but I know
that that's any more fun than jumping on
Turtles and eating mushrooms that was
just my weekend but also they did that
super mario brothers and I think it's
just an interesting thought like you
know we get all this cool technology we
keep making things look more real but
why do you want realism when you're
doing that like I like that 8-bit stuff
i like the 16-bit stuff i was a primo
sega genesis player then i moved on in
college i made it all the way to
playstation and it started crumbling i
did I was ok on PlayStation 2 then it
started up fully crumbling but I
you think it's kind interesting I'd love
to know you guys think do you think of
these games with more technology savvy
are they get more fun cuz it's all about
fun isn't it